aalia show khat is shutting down those
Brad Pitt romance rumors now I got
things started in a new interview with
vulture the 31 year old actress insists
nothing has started in fact alia
confirms she and Brad are not dating
boat were just friends alia further
addressed the speculation telling the
mag that she never expected all the
intense publicity that came with hanging
out with the movie star alia recalled
waking up one morning to find out she
was trending on twitter after the duo
was seen together at a playhouse in l.a
quote all my friends were like what's
going on and sending me photos i just
felt overwhelmed it's that feeling of
being naked in school like oh my god
everyone's looking at me now one of the
things that comes with being on TVs you
got that huge strong social media
following and then you get the haters
have you guys had to deal with any of
that oh god no not yet maybe now I'm
gonna look it up when I get home I guess
the Arrested Development stars official
dating denial comes just months after et
learned alia and Brad were simply pals
in November a source confirmed the pair
was not dating
despite being spotted out together on
multiple occasions including earlier
this month when alia and Brad
participated in a black lives matter
protest marching side-by-side as for
Brad he too has denied rumors about his
love life telling the new york times
magazine in december quote i don't know
how many women they've said i've been
dating the last two or three years and
none of it's true
one thing's for sure brad is well aware
of how universally adored he is in
september he reacted to the internet
flipping out over his sexy GQ spread
internet speak for you're doing good
babe great
[Music]